Hello everybody.
Hello, hello.
Oh my god.
Today's the day.
I my voice is pretty fucked right now I've done a lot of
super long streams.
I think the last two weeks.
I don't know.
I just love streaming for you guys.
I love hanging out with you guys and the hours pass by so
quick but has fucked up my voice a little bit.
It is a little fucked up at the moment because I haven't
really rested my throat in a while but I think like after
this week I'm gonna go rest my throat um a little bit more
because it is a little hoarse uh but I've been doing
streaming a lot the last two weeks uh and I've been like
doing more uh like longer hours than my usual hours and I'm
just you know I love hanging out with you guys uh as always
um anyway guys uh but you guys didn't know uh I know I sort
of already announced the thing anyway I mean, it's in the
title and everything, but yes, I'm in the game!
I'm my very first professional voice acting gig for gold,
gold adventure gold.
I'm super honored to be a part of something where there's a
lot of talented voice actors and voice actresses that are
part of it.
I saw a lot of them have like years of experience and have
been a part of a lot of well-known franchises and
everything.
and me too i'm in it too and then there's me guys i'm in it
too papa smurf thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you oh my god is that dokey bird fps v-a-tuber voice actor
v-tuber that's me i can add voice acting in my resume now oh
my god it was um i was so nervous about the whole thing um i
did everything in one take um It was just like, I recorded
everything.
I didn't go to like a studio or anything.
It was like an online recording.
And, oh my gosh.
I was very nervous because they wanted me, for those who
didn't watch the Fortnite stream where I explained more
about it, they wanted me to do a southern accent.
And I was just like, um.
Well, one take, as in I did like, I did everything in one
recording.
So like, I didn't stop the recording.
at all i literally was just like i i did several takes but
they were all in one recording like session so it was just
me to like uh here's the line so it would be uh what was one
of them i'm trying to remember the script right now it's
like howdy it's like howdy howdy howdy howdy like you know i
just did that so it was all it was all in like one one
recording session so i didn't pause recording at all and
then it was just me doing like several takes for each each
word um for like each of the line and everything and um what
was I gonna say fuck I lost my train of thought what was I
talking about before I already lost my train of thought oh
my god my brain is fried from all that fortnight last night
I played seven hours of fortnight and also I'll be playing
more fortnight later today after this stream I won't be
streaming it I think it's on play with us.
Gully and I finally got him to play with us.
See, we are cool, guys.
We're not losers.
We are cool.
We did it.
He said, yes, we're not losers, guys.
We wore him down until he agreed he's gonna play fortnite
overwatch with us how much are you paying him he saw how
much he missed out but not hanging out with gully and i
talking before I got distracted about the howdies.
Oh yeah, they wanted me to do a southern accent at first,
like, because the character originally, you know, because
she's southern.
The character is originally southern.
And I was like, I can't, I don't know how to do accents.
I'm so sorry.
I could, I could try my best, but I'll just sound like me.
You're, you have a crisp, pride situation going on right
now.
I'm just gonna sound like Doki.
So it's me, Doki bird.
Howdy.
E-ha.
Ye-ha, my American friend.
I am Southern.
Howdy, boys and girls.
Anyway, I was really, But yeah, you know, I was really
nervous since it's technically my very first professional
voice acting job.
Like I'm officially in a video game.
I know a lot, it is a lot of people's dreams and goals to be
like voice acting in a game.
And like, I've never really had that as a goal for myself
only because like I didn't think I would, I didn't think
people would want me to be a voice actor because I'm really
bad at like reading scripts.
I could do something naturally, but reading, I feel like you
could tell like when I'm scripted or not.
So I always get really nervous when I have to read a script
because I'm always afraid that it would sound really awkward
or stilted.
So I'm really honored that the devs wanted me to be a part
of this.
I didn't have to audition or anything.
So I'm very thankful and honored that they wanted me to be
part of their game.
And the fact that I was able to get you guys in as well.
I was like, oh, can we add the dragoons as well?
That was like a little cameo.
And they're like, yeah, yeah, of course.
We love to add the dragoons.
For those who don't know, the game just came out of early
access.
today and uh let me grab so yeah that's me that's you too so
the game just got out of early access today and it is uh the
full release today and it's 40 off i'm not actually
sponsored to do this stream by the way guys it's not really
a sponsored stream um but i'm in the game i'm a voice act
actress in the game um but i do want to you know want you
know i just want to promote it just because like I'm in it,
you guys are in it.
It's a great way to support these developers are Indies.
So it's a great way to support the Indie devs and support
them as well, especially with the fact that they gave me
this opportunity.
So I didn't even have to stream the game, but I wanted to,
because I want to support them and for letting them give me
this opportunity.
And right now it is 40% off due to the fact that it's the
launch date for the game.
so it's launch day for the game so it is 40% off right now
so here's you guys as well here's a little fun fact about
the dragoons in the game it is a gotcha system to get the
dragoons so since I'm a farmer and we have chickens on the
farm the the common the common what's the word gotcha rate
would be more so for the chickens um so the common poll rate
are the chickens so for small chicks like the regular goons
and the egg goons um there is a 40% chance the form will be
one of the two dragons so you have 40% poll chance to get
either the dragons from the regular goons and the egg goons
and then for the big chickens the chunky goons it is a 17
chance the percent chance that it will spawn from the farm
and um dragoons also give you got gifts give like a uh give
a buff to wheat because they're yellow that's their
reasoning yeah and the reasoning is that um it's because
they're yellow they give buffs to wheat um so if you see
wheat on your farm then there's a 50-50 chance that there is
a dragoon on your farm so if you see wheat there might be a
chance uh mr broken by longgoons will with a $100 DLC in
five years from now.
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Maybe if the Long Goons unionize, you guys might be able to
get yourself in the game.
But for now, I'm sorry, Long Goons.
I'm so sorry.
You just, I think they just lost your invite, guys.
Maybe you just didn't check the mail, so you couldn't accept
it in time before the deadline, Long Goons.
Doug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
playing for a couple of hours i can confidently say that
your voice acting fits really well the character it's almost
like the real doki is being forced to touch grass and work
in the tomato farm thank you thank you golden thank you the
super chat thank you thank you thank you i have a tiny
dragon called coco's um the monsters are coming thank you
let's super chat thank you thank you maybe the adventures
will return to avengers uh sorry maybe the long maybe the
avengers Maybe the long goons will return to an Avengers end
game.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Golden Helm.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sorry.
I'm brain rot.
I can't English.
I'm slurring my words.
I swear I'm not.
I'm very sober right now.
I'm just brain rotting from Fortnite last night.
I literally played seven plus hours of Fortnite.
And then also I was, I did an earlier stream yesterday.
as well watching Silent Hill, return to Silent Hill.
It was not the greatest of movies.
Yeah, I'm drunk on Fortnite.
But yeah, like I said, it was a wonderful experience.
I know like I do have a very unique voice and so it was a
cool opportunity.
I would love to do something like this again.
I would love to do more voice acting in the future if that
like, you know, if people want me to be a voice for their
character or something.
I know it's like voice acting is a very tough market, or is
it market?
Tough market to breach in or tough environment to get in
because it's a lot about like who you know and everything as
well as experiences and like the voices you can do.
Because like a lot of voice actors and voice actors are also
very talented people and they can do multiple voices and
stuff.
I, yeah, industry, sorry.
It's a very tough industry to get in.
into and very tough in the street to um to get started as as
well but i know i do have a very unique voice but the only
but my biggest problem is that i have a unique voice but i
don't have much range yeah i don't have much range in my
voice acting because i i can like i said i i don't know how
to do different voices i could just do my voice
and um i mean i could be like the you know in the past when
i was like i guess when i was younger and uh when i talked
in more higher pitched voice back then because when i first
started streaming i was very nervous so i talk like so i
talk like this a lot i can't do it right now because my my
throat is like you know sad right now my throat is like um
not sore but um it's just what's the word overuse at the
moment um so uh people said i used to sound like christian
shawl uh you know the girl who people did uh she's a voice
actress who does uh louise from bob's burgers oh yeah raspy
yeah my voice is like really raspy right now um so she does
like mabel and gravity falls louise and um bob's burgers and
she has such an iconic voice that like but she just sounds
like herself.
Like she just sounds like herself.
She doesn't do any voice, like she doesn't do any particular
voice or anything.
So like, you know, it could be like that situation or like,
you know, like, what's his name?
The guy who does Peter, Peter.
The guy who does Joe Swanson.
What's his name?
I don't remember his name.
He's like, Peter.
But he also just, But he only does his voice, but he plays a
lot of different characters because he has, yeah, Patrick
something.
I forgot his name.
Patrick Warburden.
Yeah, that's the name.
He only does his own voice.
But it's only just his voice when he plays characters.
But it's such an iconic voice that people don't fucking
care.
Because it's like literally no one else has that voice that
he does.
So maybe I could have that situation.
But I don't know.
I feel like nowadays it's more so like if you have rage I
feel like I don't know maybe maybe I don't know we don't
know what the future holds for me um but if I ever do have
another opportunity uh to you know voice act in something I
would love to um if I have a chance to audition for the vibe
like they want me to audition for a for a character I'd love
to have that opportunity um and um It was, you know, it was
cool.
It was really cool.
The fact that, you know, I'm in a game right now.
I'm in an actual video game right now, like as a character.
And you guys are there too.
I love the fact that they included you guys.
They didn't have to, but they asked if they could and they
included you guys.
And that makes me really happy because I was like, I really
wanted to have my drag wounds in there as well.
Because, you know, you guys helped built this career for me
and are like a huge part of my streaming career and a huge
part of my community so of course i would love to have you
guys i want you guys to be part of like as many things as uh
and as many things that i do um because it's not just me
it's like a team effort it's a team thing that we do
together it's not like a solo it's not so it's not like
biance where it's just i'm not biance like i'm not i'm not
biance like there's a whole team behind me that let me do
all of this and you guys a part of it that's why i always
want i always request to add you guys um in like add you
guys in as many like collaborations or events that i'm doing
uh we are biancé you're right we are biancé are we destiny's
child um uh dominar thank you super chat thank you thank you
Joki, but what about the long goons, huh?
It's like that goose meme.
Where was it?
The goose meme comic where he's chasing.
This is basically, guys, this is the long goons.
Let me say.
Well, I made this entire passionate speech about us.
These are, this was the long goons.
What about us, Joki, huh?
Why aren't we included?
Oh, I heard we included in your projects, huh?
Don't worry.
I also have some great art.
The Goblins are also top tier.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Personally, I think the RAS vocal fry in your voice sounds
great.
Can't wait to hear it while playing.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Lolly, thank you.
Thank you.
you long who's are the waluigi of the dokeepers gordon thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you when will waluigi
when will the long guns be in super smash bros yosh thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you i can call the
voice of doctor claw from og inspector gadget but only for
three lines then my voice breaks thank you the super chat
thank you thank you gordon thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you all right let's play check the game out
i haven't played this game since the last time um i was
sponsored for it so i know there's a lot of new things that
they added i mean they added me in there of course what if i
just my entire town is just gonna be farmers and then the
monsters are coming and then it's like dokey maybe it's not
a great idea when your entire farm or just farmers i'm like
but think but the food guys will never starve farmers well
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you justice for
long goons oh yeah other than that for that update um it was
raining uh this morning i don't know if it's raining i don't
know if it's still raining but like um it was raining this
morning and uh and i had to take dad out for a walk of
course and um um i decided to take him to a dog park because
there's like to get to dog park it's like we can go from
inside so i don't have to go out into the rain too long uh
to take him up and then there was another owner there i
don't know what the i guess the other dog just did not give
a fuck about rain but she was playing fetch with her dog in
the rain obviously dad hates the rain because he's a tiny
ass dog and he has short legs so like he doesn't like it
when the water touches his belly um because he's like you
cold he's like oh cold
So the moment we went to the, got to the dog part, and like
I opened the door, and obviously he saw the rain, and he's
like, no.
I was like, he's on the leash, and I was like, pulling him
out.
He's like, no.
What was that picture?
Okay, dog meme pulling leash.
It was like, it felt like that.
What was that picture of like, oh yeah, this, like this?
He basically looked like this.
not the rain my belly not my tummy though i don't want the
rain to touch my tummy
so yeah so that was him and i was like come on you gotta
poop and pee you gotta poop and pee dad and i had to pull
him out uh out to the park and then like when he got there
he saw that the lady was trying to play fetch with his dog
uh with her dog so she like uh so she like he like so he
like instantly ran over took the ball and what he okay
that's not like that's like common when he see someone else
playing fetch he would try to steal their steal their ball
and then like be like and then be like oh i'll play fetch
with you so he would usually do that he would like take
their He'll give the ball back to the owner.
And he's like, I'll be your new dog.
And he's done that before.
So I was like, okay.
He'll give the ball back.
But instead, because it was raining, he grabbed the ball and
then walked to the exit.
He just, he just, I was like, okay.
I was like, dad, no.
Like, get back, dad, come, get back the ball.
But he literally just grabbed it and just went straight to
the exit.
He did not care.
He did not look back.
And then I had to like walk, like, you know, run to him and
be like, because obviously the door is closed.
So I was like, all right, give me the ball.
Ball, give me the ball.
He's like, no.
And usually he'll give you the ball back because all he
wants to do is play fetch because he's always, he's like,
he's like one of the stocks that would actually give you
back the ball when you throw it.
Because he loves fetch.
But this time he was like, no.
i was like grabbing onto it and i was like pulling it and
after like you know like when you're when you like when
you're grabbing onto it so hard that they start standing on
their two legs because they won't let go basically like that
i was just like let go let go and he was just like standing
as two legs like no it's my no take and then i got it out
and then i tried to throw it back to the owner and and then
he ran he instantly like mock seven ran over there and then
took the ball before the owner got the ball back and then he
walked back to the exit
he like walked straight back he walked past me by the way he
walked because i was like walking to the owner and then
giving the trying to throw back the ball to them and then
And then he got the ball and then walked past me, went
straight to the exit again.
And I was like, okay, nope, all right.
I'm going to have to, and I have to, like, I have to do the
whole struggle again.
I was like, all right, all right, let go.
Let go.
And he's like, no, he got pried off my dead jaws.
I was like, dead heads like me, though, he's in his mouth.
He got pried off my dead jaws to get the ball.
And I was like, come on, dad.
Come on.
anyway so i had to hand it to the owner this time and i was
just like oh my god and then he saw me hand it to the owner
and then he walked back to the exit it's like all right job
done all right i guess we could go now it's like fuck the
rain i hate the rain let's go
so so yeah that that's that update for today my little
asshole like he this boy he's like all right i can't have
the ball i might as well fucking leave all right gold gold
adventure gold time guys i'm so excited whoa i haven't this
is gonna be a first time like i just saw the trailer and
everything so i never seen like the full voice acting in the
game itself because i recorded a lot of lines so let me see
how long the file Let me see how many how long the files was
let me double check also sound guy is here let me know About
the audio balancing sound yeah all right let me see I think
I can find it okay gold gold Farmer recordings
Whoa wait but I can actually show you guys it wait wait it's
like it's 15 minutes long I'll show you guys like the file.
I'll let you guys hear a little bit the recordings I did.
Well, hey there.
Howdy.
What's up?
So that's why I mean when I said I did various takes with
one file.
Tenderland.
That's like some here's a little sneak peek of some of the
takes that I sent over.
But it's like 55.
15 minutes worth of recordings for lines.
The script was lying.
There's so many lines to record.
That is not a southern accent.
It was just like, hey, howdy.
All right.
Let me tab into the game real quick.
Let's see here.
Pop-on.
Let me look at it.
No screen shake.
know if the with the new release uh plays down wait is that
on or off
oh wait why is the video like that whoops uh whoops sorry i
misread this you know a 360 area that's our cantonese
canadian southern farmer oh she dad even super chat thank
you thank you you say funny things you keep clicking on the
unit like in starcraft i don't know we're gonna find out
right now all right so thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you but yellow is on okay black is off okay that's
good to know because i couldn't tell there's too many golds
all right let's see make sure there's no motion blur or
anything that's always very important and all right all
right oh i can continue game It seems like the save was made
in an incompatible version.
Okay, never mind.
I can do a new game.
I remember the tutorial, sort of.
Dungeons will only spawn waves if neglected.
Send your adventures on expeditions.
I don't remember which one.
Okay, here.
Is it conquest?
I guess I should do conquest or a colony.
Tame a wild continent.
Build multiple towns.
To stake your claim.
Dungeons will, I guess like, um, which one's more fun?
Should anyone go in?
I sort of remember the tutorial.
Maybe tutorial.
Oh, is Conquest a new mode?
Oh, we should do Conquest then.
Oh, there's new pets!
A rock with a face painted on it.
Are you sure it's even alive?
Half mechanical, fully macho.
Can you unlock this doll's full potential?
Wait, this one's new.
because it was like it was like sphinx and a rock before
that's we'll try holy doll I've never tried holy doll before
that one was new
alright where's my land death has taken hold of this land
lead holy moolodons to fight the undead lay them to their
graves and slay harboring of death typically stuck between
the death what if I don't want to do that oh i have to okay
i was gonna say what if i don't want to do that i construct
a town area that can survive five days doctor thank you a
super chat thank you thank you i want recently wanted to
make my own undertale fan game where you have to duel doki
which will be impossible to defeat you because you solo all
the fiction thank you the super chat doctor thank you thank
you and i'm invincible is that what you're trying to say
damn right i am i will try conquest i haven't tried conquest
before we did the colon i think we did we definitely did
colony before i remember yeah i heard the bgms uh the music
for this is really nice it's all original music oh my god
it's the tax man oh my god i remember the tax man all right
okay guys i'm gonna do the
thought i remembered but i actually don't i clicked on one
thing and i was like i'm overwhelmed now i i i did forget
how to play this game i okay unpause the game oh sr you will
be received three perk points they allow you to unlock build
i was like that's that's a lot that's a lot to take in
Um Did I unlock buildings?
Spells?
Uh Okay, upgrades and other builds for this tutorial, but
give me one to unlock a building.
Select your starting perk.
Oh, there's my starting perk.
Apparently, um, for those who like playing what was the
game?
Majesty?
Is it called Majesty?
It's basically like uh, it's sort of like a love letter to
Majesty.
Drink E.
fight the home of mighty warriors braven where's the farm I
wonder tutorial is new like if there's new stuff they added
to tutorial or if it's like um or if it's the same tutorial
as last time all right go build their foundation in your
society but will run away when threatened fucking cowards
build for me or the Taxman will come.
Wait for the builders to finish construction.
Now that construction zone is in place, you must wait for
your builders to construct a building.
Builders will work in the order that buildings are placed.
This is your pet godpiece.
Raise it well.
Bonehead?
Oh, okay.
An enemy.
I was like, that looks very evil.
Oh, him!
Nemo!
Dad.
an enemy of spirit don't worry your god beast will protect
you it is a powerful creature that you must raise and train
it'll quickly deal with this intruder wait for the god beast
to slay the intruder an enemy of spirit okay all right do
your thing that's right dad kill him you got beer later too
apparent go get him dad come on oh shit where is he taking
him where did he take him all right we got a little reward
oh look he's so happy look at him how do i pet you i don't
remember how there's your equipment oh well we'll figure
that out later oh there it is who's a good boy dad that's
right who's my blood thirsty murderer you are that's right
you are anyway oh i can scratch his back too nice i can
brush him so that one behavior is to encourage or discourage
uh what does spring pray do your god peace has done you a
great service and he'll never know what he did rod that's
right so you'll always you'll always try to appease you're
always trying to appease me because you never know what you
did rod so you'll do everything you can to make sure you
don't up and then who's a good boy yes you are you are just
like last time
all right uh i don't know i want money so you're gonna loot
treasure workers need conditioning a virtual pet is crazy
workers need time to construct it now that your first
building is finished it's time to recruit your first
spearman all right Uh, power rank 20.
After getting burned, unable to reach the shrinking status
of...
The shining status of Moth Knight.
Today is not a rooting day for me, apparently.
Those who survive often turn to mercenary work.
With spirit in hand, these rogues will take any job at the
prices right.
Alright.
Please recruit him.
I have a job for him.
He has the zoomies.
Okay.
I told you to get me money.
Bad dad.
Go.
Go build and report him here.
Another job.
Oh.
Oh my god, that's me.
Why were you stepping?
Oh my god.
Howdy.
We're ready.
That's me.
Is it rainy season yet?
Oh, he's busy.
The pool is at the ready.
Where did she come from?
sun's up somewhere oh is it raining season yet sun's up
somewhere where's the chickens oh there's building character
living with the land as me no sun's up somewhere howdy howdy
always growing always busy is it rainy season yet always
growing like foundation that's right we're Feed the land!
Oh, where did she go?
Where did Doki go?
Where are you?
It's me!
Alright, you now have direct control over adventures.
They have free will and shall act according to their own
wants and needs.
The only way to motivate them is by offering quests for
gold.
Oh, just like the real Doki.
All you won is money.
Try to keep up.
And select exploration quests from Pop-Up.
uh explore quest fear quest i don't want them to do i don't
know i guess explore here i'm sorry explore this land she'll
only do stuff for money we came to keep free will all right
who should this drag dragon wait no fake goon actually food
there you go sorry their identity changed like five times
building character building character adventurers gain gold
quest for gold here's your new quest get more money thank
you for super chat will take a thing yeah adventures gain
gold by complete killing monsters or finding treasure some
of that gold is then taxed and returned to you while they
spend the rest as they please oh my god that's right dokey
it's time to pay your taxes dokey you can't escape even in
this game dokey you still have to pay taxes you will live
and die with paying taxes you can never avoid taxes dokey
not even in this universe the tax mouse is coming look at
that
the vtuber and gold gold adventure gold jean thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you imagine you get
reincarnated and you still have to pay taxes taxes
transcends dimension no shut up uh zero crew adventures
farmhouses were being spawning around the map they grow over
time generating more more and more gold which can then be
Weepie!
You can build it manually, so be sure.
Oh my god, I'm the main source of income!
Doki Bird is your main source of income!
Do you trust her?
It's time to expand your domain.
You can do this by destroying enemy structures.
Alright, what place an attack was.
Infinite tax loop.
Oh no, that's right.
All your income relies on me.
Your entire economy is based off of me.
Sun's up somewhere.
Sexy, dokey.
Working high.
Alright.
Good job.
There is now a lot of new land visible, which means more
exploration, more opportunities, and more chances for your
ventures to grow stronger.
Bring voice slider.
You can bring up overall and lower the sound effects
Alright, let's see.
Audio.
I don't know.
Is it game sounds?
I assume it's game.
Oh no.
That has to be SFX, right?
We'll do overall.
And then wait.
Is game sounds voice acting or is game sounds?
Uh, let's try it.
Let's actually assess this theory up.
Stay sharp.
Okay, yeah, okay.
That is SFX.
So we'll bring that down.
Alright.
Can farmer Doki fight too?
I wonder if they can.
Can't just have an entire town with farmers?
Tend the land.
Ready?
The voices.
Make the...
Never make the voices stop.
Dang.
Too many.
Is there such a thing?
has too many doggies.
They're in my head.
Why would you ever want to make it stop?
Do you hear the voices, too?
This is what goes out in my head.
Oh, we lost the 50-50.
All we got was Coco.
There you go.
there's not a lot of new land visible which means more
exploration more opportunities and more chances for your
ventures to grow stronger stronger adventures are important
for the survival of your city dungeons are filled with both
gold and monsters uh they experience outbreaks every night
and you can reduce their strength by regularly sending
adventures inside okay go do it wait We'll do the
expedition.
I don't know how to do it.
But the experience you can adventurers inside.
Select the boss location as an as an expedition target.
How do I do it?
Debs.
Defend quest.
Fear.
What the fuck?
How do I select the dungeon?
uh where's my wait where's my where's my warrior okay wait
where is he actually where the fuck is my spirit man where
did he go wait where's dad oh there she is okay now now i
can do it you can do your quest oh click that click whilst
below okay there you go all right place it and then i do it
are you gonna do it now oh i have to do get i have to pay
them complete quest all right completing won't refund wait
are they doing it dungeons are filled with both experience
outbreaks oh they are they are they're fighting the quest
right now there he goes i see him it's a one-man army hey
guys thank you for super chat thank you thank you yeah he's
doing it i see him look at him go you could do it a little
bit faster though all in him
he went in is he gonna be okay oh he's almost there He took
31 damage.
He avoided the thorny, the brambles, too.
Oh, yay!
We did it!
Retrieved the wand of Amarok.
Now that the exploration quest is complete, let's embark on
a dungeon expedition.
Expeditions are harder and more rewarding than explorations.
They usually require a strong group to succeed, but will
suppress the dungeon outbreaks much more effectively.
Click on the dungeon to start the expedition.
Now that the exploration quest is complete, let's embark.
Okay.
Alright.
So one man army.
You got this.
I think he can do it by himself.
He'll be fine.
There's nothing to worry about.
I believe.
Oh my god.
Look at sexy dokey go.
Working hard.
Always growing.
And Mothman, we trust.
Technically, I'm collecting it for everyone.
Yeah, that sounds like a tax man.
That sounds like a nerd.
Rejoice.
Tax season is here.
Yay!
Taxes!
Wait, what's that?
Neutral to words.
Wait, do I have any relationships with anybody?
How do I feel about everyone?
Oh, I don't care.
I'm just a loner.
It's surreal.
oh my god i know wait that's the same dokey she's just
helping the other dokey i was like there's another dokey and
i was like wait no that's just the same dokey all right is
he okay
all right we're just gonna wait for the dokeys to keep
growing wait what what did i
have enough human fertilizing oh I can decide if I will
defend.
We got to defend the farm.
It's so important.
How do I unclick it?
I wish I could see what this says.
Oh!
It's that.
That's going to defend this farm.
That's what he's doing.
Yeah, there can be multiple dokees.
Your entire town relies on the dokee economy.
money is in my hands click on the quest oh oh so that's
defending right now and also farming that's right you got to
protect the dokey line exactly all right you see still
finishing the expedition right now oh my gosh he's so oh my
god Wait!
Oh my god, wait!
There's a tomato!
Okay, that's cute.
I don't know if it was an Easter egg, but I do like that
they included that.
I like that.
That's cute.
I didn't even see it.
Oh, level one chicken.
And then there's me.
The tomato farm!
It's real!
Yay!
He got it!
Upbreaks happen every night in the following dungeon.
engine.
Data grows progressively stronger.
Next, thank you.
Thank you.
It may be a good idea to hire more spearmen to prepare.
I'll also give you another perk point to choose a ruler's
gaze ability.
Okay.
Another perk point.
Let's go.
What do I unlock?
Drive faster when you're looking at them.
Burn your enemy just by looking at them.
I'll do healers.
I feel like healers might be better.
I'll record another spearman.
Oh, Max, never mind.
They're like, you can recruit another spear, man.
I was like, all right.
All right, let me heal them.
I'm looking.
I'm looking at you.
Get healed.
I'm looking.
All right.
Your final tool and keeping your city standing.
Press the defense.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
Press the what?
Oh, oh my God.
Someone help her.
Oh, my God.
Someone.
Okay, actually, maybe not that urgent.
Someone saved Dokilan!
What do you mean, time's up?
I didn't even get a chance to hear!
Okay, wait, maybe not as urgent.
Not as urgent.
Not, not as urgent.
There we go.
Not as urgent.
Protect.
There we go.
We're fine.
Oh, look at that.
The land is saved.
Let's tax her real quick.
I like how you're like, wow, you didn't die anyway.
Taxman is here.
He's like, don't forget to Yo, you survived the...
You survived the ambush.
Anyway, $20, please.
Taxes waited for no one.
Glad you're safe.
Thank you for the tax bill.
Nice.
I did it.
Alright, I think I'm ready.
Now...
Now I'm ready for conquest.
Now I'm ready for your conquest, guys.
I have a girl.
This region is...
What do I get from these?
I travel through your party and counts as strange travelers
sitting aside.
Something about the stranger pulls you in.
They command the convoy to stop.
Against your guard's wishes, you approach them.
And with barely a visible smile, they offer you a choice
between one or two trinkets.
I'll grab the three.
as you travel through the winding roads between towns your
party encounters a strange traveler sitting at the side of
the road something about the stranger pulls you in and you
command the convoy to stop against your guard wishes you
approach them in a barely visible smile they offer you a
choice between one or two trinkets i'll take gold because
wait isn't silver more expensive than gold okay but that's
like in 2026 we're talking about like fantasy medieval times
Wait, why is she why does she smile more for the golden
dagger is it cursed?
I don't know.
I don't like the sight of her I don't like the sight of her
giving me that evil smile But like the whole game is based
off of gold and not it's not it's not called silver silver
Adventure silver it's called gold gold adventure gold so I'm
gonna go final answer golden dagger
suddenly the world tears away.
In a blink, you stand in the desolate fields.
Corpses of creatures and falling enemies litter the horizon.
Your flags and banners rise above them.
Beneath your feet, the blood-soaked earth is still warm.
The red of battle fresh from your conquest.
Then you blinked again.
You're back on the lonely road where you stood moments
before.
The stranger who gave you the blade is gone.
All that remains is a dagger in your hand.
It's golden edge, faintly humming power.
You have gained a martial reward.
I mean, it seems, I'm winning the fight, Like, the red bat
of freshman, but I won, right?
So that's not too bad.
It doesn't seem that curse if it means I won, right?
Right, guys?
Doesn't seem that bad.
all right the region is immense by the arachnoid cult whose
sanctum lies some distance to the west of your civilization
forge the path through the domain and end their dark okay i
can get the yonder a girl the unworthy wavering gaze or
angel all right i think we all know what you're gonna pick
guys i think i know what the dragoons want me to get with
the three choices we were given I don't think it's even a
question.
Why are there snakes?
This is your construction crew?
Who are these guys?
Who are they?
Okay, that doesn't...
Oh, then they're very greedy.
Okay.
Oh, is that the yonder girl?
The snake likes you.
Oh!
Oh, she controls the snake!
These delinquents pine for your attention.
Only care for you and their pet servant.
Oh!
Okay.
all right i get it the snakes work for them but let's build
a forge and let's build a forge we got this and then we can
build a market too so we have the money and then you know
what build everything and then we'll build an inn all right
there we go i keep building it should be fine if i oh i have
bricks right now uh spell reveals territory from afar spell
costly spell that instantly transports units a dark spell
that conjures a where's my money okay i have a 3000 um a
dark spell that conjures a skeleton who attacks
indiscriminately the more corpses in this spell area of
effect the more powerful that can't be too bad as long as
like none of my other characters are there oh some apparent
woes inside of you are two woes
wait i can make them into gold
wait a minute
i could turn them into gold I hate that.
Let's get cast your spells to it.
Alright, let's get the healing one.
I think we're good.
Oh my god, why did... Doki, why did you put your farm next
to the fucking dungeon?
Okay.
This Doki, a dumb Doki.
Doki, why would you get your farm out of here?
Get it closer.
You could have been...
Your farm could be anywhere else, Doki.
This Doki is stupid.
Why would you put your farm next to the fucking dungeon?
This Doki, unfortunately, is not that smart as the other
Doki's.
What is this?
Allows the force to produce.
Okay, let's grab some.
Yeah, let's make that for them.
Okay.
enter for this crafting flow income production time general
oh i can buy stuff there's like dwellers okay who lives
there oh upgrades okay oh that's cool there's a lot of stuff
to learn in this game oh there's the tax man oh unknown dad
but huh
But...
Furry.
I don't know, based on past Turkey's Minecraft building
skills, this checked out.
Thank you for the super chat for here.
Thank you, thank you.
Dude, not dad.
Alright, okay, new...
but
dad but woman
all right there we are let's see market all in producing
buildings gain additional gold wait how much gold do I have
I still have a lot of gold so we're good improve income all
right we got I feel like we should improve income so so my
farm can make more money I feel like Those who escape I feel
like I can attack this right now Right?
I should be able to Dad Oh true Wait that's a better name
Mom
That's actually that is the better That is a better name
Alright we got We have anything else we have to build Oh do
we have forge yeah we do we have the forge we have an end oh
we don't have a quest board all right let's get the quest
board in here so my guys can start doing quests all right
attack oh oh fuck oh my god there's a baby chick male chick
we know what's gonna happen Chicken tenders.
There you go.
Alright, go.
Go over there and start killing.
Wait, wait.
Start killing this guy.
Wait a minute.
Is that?
Oh, wait.
No, he's part of the forge.
I was like, oh my god, is he an enemy?
I just thought that guy was like, wait, kill him.
Kill this dragon.
He's just a staff member.
He's just chilling.
God He's actually just trying to do his job He's just trying
to help Alright
What?
Why does she start speaking Japanese?
Alright, oh we did it!
Nice job, Yondori girls!
Nice job!
You did great!
How do I start using my spells?
goal list destroy the sluggler limelight blob master have 10
yonder is at the same time where's my spell book though oh
there it is it down here oh it is i mean it's okay they can
go drinking it should be fine all right let's get the grab
the boss and then and then wait I start this yet and not do
it or weapon oh now it should work right huh oh there you go
now it should work all right all right guys plenty of quests
to go wait is that my crow the only creature in this row he
seems to share your love for shiny things oh I can't rename
him I don't even know if he's mine I don't know he's just
chilling there what the fuck you know what I'm gonna summon
Let's summon him just a oh never mind he is he?
Are these mine or okay, they're fighting each other they're
just gonna fight each other that's fine Oh shit What did
they kill?
Can't tell Okay, nice is there any I guess that's earning me
gold right now Survives three days.
Okay, that's all I have to do.
I just gotta live for three days I have the market I have
the forge and I have a quest board what does the quest board
do does it tell me they don't know what I should read it
doesn't tell me so they don't know what the quest board does
I should get an archer tower just in case um I don't oh I
haven't done it fine all right let's put you let's take you
away from all the death put it here and then we'll attack
here all right you can be the smarter dokey because you
didn't you didn't put your farm in front of a okay you put
your farm in front of the dungeon stupid dokey
wait what is cosmetic
Oh, what is this?
Oh, there's gold here!
Escavate that, guys.
Oh my god, I can send all the yonderers in.
Alright, go in here and retrieve the wand.
Go, yonderers!
Go!
Dumb and dumber dokey.
And then there's...
There.
Chicken nuggets.
And there's another chick.
Whether it's chicken breast.
There we go.
We did it, Yonderous!
We did it!
Send in the Yonderous!
That's like actually all I have.
They're all Yonderous.
Send them in!
No, that's not a dragon.
I don't think so.
Is it?
No, I don't think it's spawning in.
Wait, where is he?
I would know if it's a dragon.
See, it has legs.
Look at him.
Yeah, I knew that wasn't a dragon.
Okay, there's a catacomb over there.
But he's yellow.
Do you know what is also yellow?
Me.
Am I also a dragon?
No, I'm dokeybird.
Wait, someone kill these guys.
There's clack, clack.
No, Sebastian!
No!
Get out of here, Sebastian!
Oh, goodbye, Sebastian.
Goodbye.
That's on Sebastian.
That's on him.
We told him to leave.
But Sebastian wouldn't leave.
What's this guy doing?
What the fuck?
Attack!
Stop him!
Yonder is!
Go!
Where's my Yonder is?
Okay.
I might have to build another arrow tower here just in case.
I don't trust them.
There's big S.
I have every...
I think I have every upgrade, right?
Like how the yonder grows.
They're just...
Are like Japanese voice actors.
That bloody knife.
Let's just pick one of these perks related to the structure.
Um...
07 for Sebastian.
Oh, yeah, I can fast forward this.
Almost forgot.
Okay, well, I sold a lot of stuff.
Oh, oh, no!
Not the wave!
Uh!
Oh, no more fast forward!
No more fast forward!
Oh, a crack of thunder.
The vampire count, Lombroso, appears before you.
You have discovered my tomb, mortal, he sneers.
Now choose.
Shall you perish?
shall you provide living souls to satisfy my eternal thirst
a few lives were a small price i'll never sacrifice my
citizens even if the dookies are a little special so be it
prepare yourself for my undead horror oh oh no oh no maybe
oh guys did i made a little oopsie
Oh, no.
I hope I didn't make a little oopsie there.
Oh, I don't have gold anymore.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
Everything will be fine.
My yonder is.
My yonder is gone.
Oh, oh, that's a lot of people.
Oh, that's a lot of people hanging out on that side of the
area.
All right, we got to...
defend here oh there that's a lot of people over there
surely everything will be fine surely okay i need more
dokeys to start popping up guys where are all the dokeys
let's see we're defending the area
okay that's good my yondering my army of yonderers are doing
their thing okay wait i can some oh wait i need gold for
that i should start saving up my gold all right yeah it's
one dokey per farm it is okay maybe i should
reward too small god damn it mom why are you so greedy okay
i'm just gonna wait for my money to build up still need
someone to excavate this how do you mean there's gold there
how
is that not enough
excuse me how much more do you want oh my there's no way
okay let's see oh it's still too small it's a thousand gold
is still small for you okay how much gold do they what I
need to cancel this one uh complete quest oh actually
already gave the gold the jokies would do it they wouldn't
they wouldn't do it for free who am I kidding wait mail oh
wait I named that I forgot I I gave that name I was like,
wait, mail chick?
Oh, that's, that's, oh, that's, I gave that name.
It's still daytime.
I mean, everything seems fine.
Oh.
Whoa.
All right, that's fine.
I don't like how...
Oh, wait, there's another farm!
All right, you get back.
You're gonna farm down here.
Oh, your inventors have unearthed the trove of ancient tomes
from a wizard's tower far to the north.
You've decided to give one of your godbeats to learn from,
but which one?
A star charts and mysterious potents give them a tone of
strange and terrible...
Strange and terrible secrets!
Pours over the page, thinking deeply about their contents.
You give them much to learn from.
Dark names and bloody rich rituals That may echo in their
minds For decades Good!
Get stronger, mom!
Stronger!
Yes!
Someone's up somewhere.
Which dokey are you?
You're gonna be a regular dokey.
And then we have Coco and Bok.
Is that?
Oh my god, we're losing The Gotcha!
How?
all right where's his where's her kid bach we're losing the
dragon gotcha
uh popcorn chicken
lesson or is it raining season yet all right let's see i'm
gonna start attacking this jesus where is these lightnings
coming from don't forget to pay your adventures oh shit
whoops i just noticed it i was like whoa that's a lot of
money that i owe oopsie i was like what do you mean debts
all right still have a bunch of yonderers they're doing
their job
where's my other yonderers are they all at the bar oh yeah
they're at the bar they're they're not ready they're not
here to work anymore they're just they're just here to
drink let's see my can I afford the castle upgrade yet oh I
can increase this castle health yeah okay I need more
residents yeah I collect I only know how to collect what do
you mean pay
all right so what does the quest okay the quest is just
quest quest quest quest all right that unlocked the area
holy shit someone help isabella oh wait she's healing
herself that's fine never mind no need to help her she's got
it yeah she's got this she can 1v5 hello oh hello is she
okay did someone Hello?
Okay, bye, Isabella.
Bye, I guess.
I'll just let...
Oh my god, look at him.
Look at Isabella, go!
Oh my god, she healed herself!
She's gaming!
She's emoting.
She's doing a Fortnite dance!
I have $2,000 now.
What's this?
The hero has.
I make that?
I don't remember making this.
Wait, I should have upgrades now.
Because I...
Thriller's upgrade was this.
Did one of my popcorn chicken escaping?
I was getting... Oh, wait.
I was like, what is popcorn chicken doing at the market?
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, oh god, okay, oh that's not good.
Oh that's not good.
Oh, they're here.
They're all here now.
I was like, what's that noise?
What's that noise of somebody, like, breaking my house or
something?
It's okay, the Yonderers are here.
My snakes and Yonderers are here.
Oh, that's a lot.
Oh, that's a lot of people.
good that's good okay they're repairing everything is fine
the snakes are doing its thing they're doing their snake
duties you know what see guys look everything is okay i
think we're winning i think i'm doing okay
yeah we could technically attack this too like fuck it
attack them all
I survived day one.
Destroy the catacomb.
Fallen 36 out.
Build 16.
What else do I need to build?
16 structures?
I build everything I can build.
Oh, I guess I could build another market, right?
forage build behind everyone the work okay we don't need a
all right includes for mysterious rangers i think i can oh
shit what the fuck all right is everything is everybody oh
my god it's the rats the rats are here it's the fucking rats
okay we can build more we're gonna build more archer towers
why donkeys donkeys stop building your farms in the enemy
territory oh my god another wave okay it's all right
everything is fine everything is fine yeah that's a little
three oh my god please please please like i'm sorry i would
love to give you attention right now
oh my god oh my god there's too many yonderers that want my
love oh my don't you know what oh my god okay okay
everything will be fine uh
recruit as long as they're low as long as their adventure
recruits faster but have less help 10 self-recruitment cost
reduction okay that's good
Doki, maybe if you are not, maybe, Doki, maybe, oh my god,
maybe if you're not in the middle of the enemy line, you
wouldn't be running around.
Okay, it's fine, everything is fine.
All right, chicken, teriyaki, art cocoa, all right, ready,
dumber, doki.
Okay.
It's all okay.
Everything's okay.
Oh, my God.
Please.
I have a job to do.
Taxes.
My lord, Rufus had an accident.
We pay your attention to me now.
Who's Rufus?
Who?
Rufus.
Wait.
Rufus?
Oh my god, the tag!
Mom!
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't think...
Guys, maybe having an army of yonder girls might not have
been the best idea.
Guys...
Maybe, maybe, guys.
Maybe, guys.
Oh my god, Dad.
It's like, you killed her.
Guys, maybe you think maybe we just can't fix her?
Guys, guys, do you think?
Is that it?
We just can't fix her?
No way.
Just a little oopsie.
it can't be no we just need more yonderous you're right we
just need more how do we get more yonderous though dad's
angry he's like how could you let her die i didn't know oh
my god he's actually angry hey hey i gotta feed don't worry
nothing bad's gonna happen while I feed him.
Alright, I'm back.
You're right, guys.
It's my fault.
I just didn't give her enough attention.
You're right.
You're so right.
Oh my god, who did you kill?
Who, wait, where did that blood come from?
Who did?
Oh my god, what do you mean?
$2,000.
Wait, when did I owe that much money?
Oh, that is a lot of people.
people on that side oh I'm so broke I am so broke Doki's
please Doki's make more money Doki's oh where are the why
are they not getting shot at okay I'll put it here all right
mom mom mom's back oh there are so many people on the other
side but go on strike dokey dokeys make me more money build
more guilds i can't even build a guild all i have is an inn
a forge
how do i even have more guilds
I would if I could.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
Which one?
Which yonder needs my attention?
Which one needs my attention right now?
Okay, we gotta get rid of this one, though.
Wait, Coco.
my lord hasan had wait that's a dragon dragon that's a
dragon wait there he is go go go go get oh my god coco go no
no no no no no no no okay coco get over here oh my god there
he is he got a dragon
oh my god we got him there he is look at him he's so tiny
he's running away doesn't want
Oh my...
See, I told you guys.
I told you guys the dragoons look different.
There he is.
Look at that.
We won the gotcha, guys.
I told...
No, man.
What are these guys?
Blood, girl.
From these slaying nearby, fouls...
And...
Who are they?
Who are these?
Who are these blood women?
Who are these blood women on my in my town?
Who are they?
Yeah, I was like, how did they get here?
All right, yeah, I renamed Coco.
Coco number three.
Drumstick, chicken drums.
Oh yeah, drumstick.
there you go can I even like excavate any of these so me
like oh wait she's dead unless here here yonder it yeah
right right oh my god she's running she's running she's
running and she's hiding I have so many things left I wonder
if I have to let's see my frames are getting a little choppy
I think there's too many snakes you think that's possible to
just have too many snakes on screen you know what fuck it
let's kill him I believe oh my god do not kill him do not
try and kill him I do not I do no longer believe there are
bosses coming in please focus on protecting the land Never
mind.
Focus on protecting the land.
Oh, that was bad timing.
That may or may not have been very bad timing for me.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
I'll summon him.
And then...
Okay.
I'm going to use this healing for somebody.
Is everybody okay?
There we are.
I healed.
Oh.
Oh my god, oh my god!
I heal!
Oh, this is, don't worry.
I have a little bit more money.
Bonehead here.
Oh no, my arrows.
Heal!
Who the fuck is Norman?
Oh, that's the blood people.
Okay.
Oh, that is so expensive.
don't worry i can still heal oh i don't know what it
destroyed i don't know what it destroyed things are not
looking so good on that side but i think the right side is
doing all right
oh oh that's okay the farm's okay everything is fine we have
an idea i have an idea where my where are my arrows oh i
can't remember because i have to rebuild okay it's just
these guys oh oh i survived it's okay it's okay we don't
know what and then we never know what happened in that town
i get and we'll never know what happened in that town but we
survived we survived matters.
We'll never know.
We're like, oh, got the three days.
Bye, guys.
Finished my shift.
Gonna clock out now.
We don't talk about it.
They all lived.
As we all know, they all lived happily ever after.
All of them.
Juan George, think of the magenta soup?
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki, today's my birthday.
I just want to say thank you for cheering me up with your
streams through some bad times I have these days.
Of course, a dragon.
And of course, Hong George.
Oh, you're feeling a lot better.
Thank you for being here and supporting the stream and
hanging out with us today in the dragon community.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Hong George.
Yeah, happy.
Alright.
We're still missing.
We still haven't got, um, the chonki-gun or the egg-gun yet.
We did see regular good.
We saw a regular dragon.
Oh my god.
The yonder is her back.
Okay, I'll get rid of this.
And we're gonna try and build more.
Okay, I'm gonna build.
The forge.
Um.
Is the quest for just ascetic, guys?
Does anyone know?
No, I can't build this.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah?
Okay, so I won't waste my money on it then.
Okay.
Alright.
Mom.
I wish your names are permanent when you...
For conquest mode.
That would be nice.
That would be cool.
That'd be pretty neat.
Oh, three heroes created.
Okay, survive five days.
Okay, I was struggling with three, but let's aim for five
now.
Chilling inside.
She's a little scary, guys.
Just a little bit.
But maybe it's because I'm just so scared of loving her too
much.
Oh!
Old man.
Old dragon.
Oh my god, there he is!
Old chonky, chonky dragon.
There we go.
Like, look, that was, that was, they called the, they, they,
The game called you guys.
Well, not me.
Doki.
Wait.
Lucky Doki.
Gamba Doki.
She was the one that got the Chonky-goon.
And...
Let me click on the little bird.
Okay.
Popcorn.
Chicken.
Alright, let's see.
What do we need?
Um...
Where's the...
Oh, there you go.
I need to buy this.
Knife production.
Uh...
Oh.
Crafting economy.
Improves income of all farms.
Income of all farms, please.
We're a farmer market.
Taxman's coming.
I don't even know where to put the...
I guess I'll put one here.
Just in case.
What's over here?
I wonder what's over here.
I'm just gonna get rid of all the dungeons around me just in
case
build more guilds I can't I'm restricted from guilds they
have to come to me oh never mind JK JK I got the guild
alright even though it's attendant nature you need a place
to rest your let's recruit range light bringers and beast
tamers oh wait i can get them let's get the munistry i think
we all know what we want i think we all know what we want
guys oh wait warrior hall mage tower magic angels we get
which one do we want knowledge power or goblins
which one go on mages mothmen or goblins I don't even know
what the mage oh they're also moths moths, moths or gobs
moth mages alright we'll grab the moth mages and then I'll
get the heal I'm ramming the heals I feel like the heals
will benefit us a lot um I'll put one um archer let's get
the munis tree real quick and then oh one of the king's
warriors requests to stay in the night um the arm their army
has been around they are fleeing a horde of how shall you
treat them
you may stay the night but after they must return to the
front there's a war to be won yeah i feel like that your god
be watches as you send the warrior back to the front with
trumpets and cheering how glorious they think not knowing
the poorest soldier is headed to their doom it's all right i
mean they die they die for their kingdom for the peace of
the kingdom they die doing what they love all right let's
grab muladins let's get moving all right there she goes all
right now Get that dungeon.
For Dokilan!
Exactly.
What's that?
Oh, it's a Coliseum.
Wait, why are you doing here?
Mom!
What the fuck?
What the fuck are you doing here?
He's doing it for the love of the game.
She did not have to be there, by the way.
It was just for the love of the game.
I need to build a mage tower.
I don't have enough money.
I'm poor right now.
Just mob things.
Alright, we just gotta wait.
Oh, there she is.
There she goes.
Oh.
Bye.
There she goes.
Just chilling.
yeah it's like majesty it's basically like my donkey oh my
donkey what
all right uh we need some help why why would you pick here
what oh my god okay don't worry don't worry they're coming
over the dokees don't all the dokees just have no sense of
that's the dokees just like i'm just here she really okay
all right oh my god that a chonky goes no i have no survival
instinct right now i have to repair it before i can
reposition dokee to a safer area I mean it should be safer
Here technically
We'll put you I'll put you here This is actually much more
safer Oh my god there's another There's another chonky-goon
Dragon And then you My little guy You Can be Yeah chicken
tenders oh hey wait how does how do we open guys you know
how to open the chest oh how do you open the chest guys
yeah I'm glad there's repositioning because my dokeys have
no survival instinct at all
like thank god we live in 2026 I think all dokeys We have
never survived.
It would definitely not be survival of the fittest.
Or is it explore quest?
How to open chest?
Do explore?
Maybe?
Maybe.
Maybe that's how you do it.
Also attack here too.
Fuck that place.
Oh, I don't have money anymore.
Fuck.
I keep spending all my money.
I need more dokeys.
Jokies, I need you to farm.
Oh, another Chonky-goon.
All right.
You know, Hon George, happy birthday.
You get to be a dragon.
And then this one.
Well, hey there.
Hey.
All right.
Dude.
I'm not gonna survive, dude.
All right, and then chicken, uh, chicken breast.
I'm so hungry.
You can tell I'm really hungry right now.
You can, yeah, it's sort of obvious that I might be hungry.
I might be pretty hungry.
Oh, no.
Another Doki!
Oh my god, Doki, please.
Please.
Okay.
Let me see if I can...
I'm gonna put your house here.
All right.
Oh, he's busy.
Let's see.
What Doki are you?
Dangerous Doki.
Yeah.
Cladding the seed.
Sun's up somewhere.
Blocked together.
Always growing.
Watch where you're stepping.
Reap what you sow.
Tend the land.
Well, hey there.
Working hard.
Reap what you sow.
Always growing.
So walk together.
Howdy.
The voices never stop.
Did they get it?
How many don't get the chest?
The voices, they don't stop.
Alright.
I still don't have a lot of...
Okay, we still need spearmen.
Oh, we don't have spearmen.
I don't have money for the mage tower.
I'm broke right now, so I gotta wait.
I'm gonna wait until...
Get out of my head!
I'm gonna pass forward for the taxman.
Alright.
Surely the taxman.
So I can get taxed faster.
Alright, Rufus.
That's... This is me.
Oh, shit!
Oh, shit.
Just because I started taxing!
Oh, George!
Run!
I started taxing and the odds started coming.
Oh no.
Wait.
Oh my god, save him!
Stokey!
Of course, of course it killed not gonna survive.
Doki's house.
Of all the Doki's in attacks.
Her fate was foretold.
Oh my gosh.
Doki.
Are you gonna see cause of foreshadowing?
Where will she go?
She lost her home.
How will she survive?
It was a destined.
You promised fortune upon her.
How was I supposed to know?
She was not gonna survive.
Who could have known?
Guys, who could have known?
No one could have foretold.
Who could have known?
She's homeless now.
I didn't mean for her to be homeless.
I thought she would survive.
I didn't know she was not gonna survive.
That's crazy that happened.
You put a death, you're like, now one is homeless too.
I can buy a new house?
How do I buy a new house for her?
Or how?
Where is she?
Wait, Doki.
Doki, where are you?
Oh my god.
The fact that farmers, you always...
need a farmer you can you don't have to have all the other
units but i'm always there i just realized that i'm always
here you can't avoid me in your game because my farmers you
need me to survive you need my money yeah i am essential
worker yeah i'm an essential worker you need me
wait how do i buy guys how do i buy another farm guys my
dokey's homeless there is no escape does anyone know my
dokeys are home my not gonna survive dokey needs a home
let's see moth mage
I think they just spawned.
You just spawn.
Okay, that's...
Crazy?
Not me.
Alright.
You hear that?
She's not crazy.
You need a doctor a few times a year.
Lori may be a few times a year, but you need a farmer a few
times every day.
Exactly.
Lolly, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why are they attacking each other?
Wait, what?
Stop!
Stop fighting!
Bad catitude.
And if we're holes through...
Wait, why did they attack each other?
They hate each other or something?
They don't even have any relationship.
Oh, that...
What is that?
Oh.
Does he look friendly, guys?
You think...
Guys, do you think he's friendly?
Do you think he's friendly, guys?
Surely he's friendly, right?
Is that not...
Oh, not gonna...
Wait!
Not gonna survive, Doki has relocated!
Okay, you still chose one of the first...
Okay, there we go.
You...
Why don't you live?
Oh my god, she found a new home.
She rebuilt.
Alright, not gonna survive Doki.
You're gonna live here.
You gotta stop fucking being so far away from everyone.
Oh.
Wait, I can't see anything.
Oh no.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, he blessed me!
Wait, it was a good thing!
I was blessed, guys.
He blessed my farm.
See, I told you.
I told you he was friendly, guys.
You didn't believe me.
You judged the book by its cover.
Look at that.
Get Mandar.
Or Darmad.
Get Darmad.
That's what you get.
Not all of them are evil.
Be a Darmad.
And I'll do it again.
He was friend-shaped.
I knew he was friend-shaped, guys.
What is that anyway?
Like, gold for blood.
What is the debt system?
Anyway, like...
How come I'm, like, in debt?
Wait, if I build more...
Okay, wait, I'm gonna put another fountain here just in
case.
Just in case.
It gave me, like, XP or something.
It gave my heroes, like, more...
Like, she's level 15 now.
So she's a higher level.
Alright.
V312.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
I'm escaping from reality until this Monday.
No real news or family business.
Thank you for a stream, Doki.
You're the essence of one.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you've been enjoying this stream.
Alright, let's see.
farming yay she finished farming let her get her go all
right and we also got the all the uh oh we limited the blob
since when oh wait no oh yes all right uh earn additional
gold reward all right we'll creates a field of flowers more
of a nest really but a traditional name pillar of holding
holiness creates a field of flowers fiber here is
permanently gained unpredictable amount oh let's get that do
these like okay
Oh, your adventures have captured the Adrean with slaying
travelers in the woods.
She's brought before you and your godpiece to be judged.
What will you do?
Um...
Does this affect whatever I do in the future?
Like...
I feel like we'll return to her.
I mean...
majority of the people in my town aren't even human so it
should be fine your god beats watches as you release the
dread from her bonds we have trespassed in her home to
explain to blame her Italian will be deeply unjust you
taught them a lesson today that Avengers matter less than
compassion for others yeah I was gonna say I'm gonna say
like I don't even have people in my town does it do I really
care that's none of my business There's no humans in my
town.
My taxman's a fucking rat.
Who cares what happens to them?
She's not killing my people.
As long as she's not killing my people, I'm fine.
Alright, torture chambers.
Do that.
And then a boss location too.
If anyone wants to get that dungeon.
Death, you pay your due.
My lord, Don't Keeper had an accident?
Oh my god, the taxman!
Oh my god.
No more taxes.
Don't Keeper has died.
What do you mean?
the taxman died how are we supposed to get tax now but how
oh no it's time to get a new dokey like what do you mean how
did the taxman die what a shame no taxes oh man oh look oh
look see At least mom's alive.
Hello, mom.
I heard you can level them up.
I wonder how you can do that.
Or she's just going to stay like a little...
Like a child forever.
Where's mom?
Alright, don't go drinking right now.
And the face deserves a punch.
Oh, she loves Hatties.
Oh, just because she killed the taxman?
Is it a quest board?
She has a cute design.
I like it.
Chilling inside.
Buying beer.
Oh, oh.
Oh, gawking.
Sleeping, recovering, happiness in an end.
All right, you deserve to sleep.
Um...
Do we complete this?
Oh, we already completed it?
Nice.
You know what?
Let's start.
Oh, I do not have a lot of people.
Never mind.
No.
i do not have a lot of people protecting my place i still
have five more days oh this is not good oh my god and
there's there's only three people in this town and you still
are fighting each other guys stop stop fighting
okay we'll build another one so we can have more moolodons
all right i mean Fuck it.
Maybe...
Maybe nobody's gonna invade us.
Maybe no one's gonna invade us.
Maybe...
Alright.
Okay, don't worry.
We still have plenty of time.
Oh, wait, we did it.
Oh my god, Doki.
No, not next to the Doki.
No.
to the dungeon, Doki.
Please, Doki.
We have so much space everywhere else, Doki.
Alright, just hang up with these Doki's.
Not right next to the scary dungeon.
Well, hey there.
Alright.
Uh.
Natural.
Natural selection.
Doki.
What?
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, speaking of natural selection.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, everything is not fine.
Oh, everything is not fine.
Uh, defend, please.
Defend.
Oh, no.
Someone's gotta defend this area.
Okay, I just, I can build more arrow towers.
I cannot build more arrow towers.
Alright.
Okay, why do you always...
Oh, my God!
It gone!
Oh my god, Aikon, Aikon, Aikon!
Wait, there he is!
We found all the dragons!
Aikon!
Oh my god, there he is!
Is something...
Oh wait, no, we're rebuilding.
Oh my god, we have all the dragons.
Oh, please do not, please, please do not kill another one.
I beg of you.
Do not kill another one.
I swear to God, if I built the arrow tower and someone is
dead, I swear to you, God, if I build an arrow tower and I
found out someone has not survived.
Guys, we did it.
We found all of them.
Chicken.
All right, chicken.
Yeah.
All right.
All my dokees are just going to hang out here.
Uh...
What our stuff is around here?
We can excavate this.
Do we have any...
Do we finish anything here?
They have a population of...
I am not gonna have a population...
Wait, am I not slain all wolves then?
I thought I have.
I guess not.
Where are the other wolves?
Maybe they're like right here.
Alright.
I'll put an adventure quest right here and see what happens.
Why are they scared?
What is that?
Oh.
Pegasus, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Oh, that's...
Oh, wow.
Of course, a dungeon pops up In the middle of Dokilan.
In the middle of Dokistan.
Good foundation.
Oh.
That's not good.
That's not good for her.
Alright.
We gotta take out the...
We gotta control the pest situation.
Not very ideal.
That it spawned in the middle of Dokilan.
Not the best.
Alright, mom's got this.
She's exploring.
Oh.
Paid off my debt.
Does anyone know where the debt comes from?
Like, uh...
Like, where that comes from in terms of, like, why I had to
pay debt off if I owned this place?
Alright.
Are you doing okay in the dungeon?
Morale is high right now.
Yeah, like, am I swiping my credit card or something?
Like, where is it coming from?
Oh, it's the wages.
You mean they're not working for free?
How dare they not work for free in Doki Lons?
I feel like, you know...
Oh my god, another fucking rat town.
Wait, who's Spark?
Oh, that's just one of the people there.
Okay.
Oh, morale is very low right now.
They really want to make bread.
Joki, it's a game about gold.
Of course, they're not going to work for free.
Their whole thing is about gold.
As you can see, where you gain money and expenses?
It's alright.
Everything will be fine.
Oh, are they fighting a rat king right now?
I'm going to watch.
Oh, wait.
There's more.
Oh!
Is there...
Oh, I would like to raise those.
recruitment cap, actually.
That's actually good.
And I actually have another um, what is this?
Druids may appear cute but aren't what they seemed.
Moth Mage.
Did someone die?
Oh.
Oh, that's awkward.
Uh, alright.
It's a little awkward.
Ooh.
Oh.
You know, if they don't, if they stop fighting each other,
maybe they'll die less.
That's all I'm gonna say, is these people stop fighting each
other.
Okay.
We're at the droid, and then we have another moolod in.
Okay, nice.
Oh, we got the...
Okay, there's the wolf dead.
Destroy the wolf lair.
Yeah, I'll take it.
Shoot cannonballs or heroes explode on death.
Creatures you capture, Dila.
Oh,
I want that.
That sounds good.
How do I use this, though?
Wait, how do I capture a creature?
All I know how to do is kill.
I just know how to kill.
I don't know how to capture.
Oh my god.
The thing is, when it's night time, all the rats are gonna
come out here.
I can feel it.
I can feel the rat army.
Oh my god.
Which... All right, dokeys.
A fucking chorus.
Of course.
Of course you want to spawn there.
anywhere.
Uh...
Put you here.
Oh, nope, there's the rats.
Oh, there they are.
Oh, the rats are here.
Oh, they're all here now.
Who would have thought?
There they are.
Oh, there they are.
Alright, let's put this here when the rats start coming in.
I think we'll need it.
Alright, Which Doki is this?
Oh my god, there's another Chonky-goon!
We have so many Chonky-goons.
Okay.
Not so bright, Doki.
Alright.
Who wants to be this dragon?
You know what?
Knight bot.
Wait, we got two dragons!
Oh, shit.
Oh my.
Okay, wait, wait.
We got two dragons.
Oh my god.
All right.
Let's defend.
Defend the farm.
Okay.
Oh, this is not great.
Oh, this is not good.
This is not looking too good.
Oh, my.
Oh, not so bright, Doki.
Oh, goodbye.
Night pod, run.
Oh my god.
it's okay everything is fine wait did anyone die oh a lot of
people died um another maid okay it's okay we killed the
wolf boss we killed the wolf boss it's fine it's fine it's
fine the not so bright nightbot lives nightbot and quack
lives did it.
Night Pot and Quack.
Thank God I didn't name it.
Night Pot was like 1 HP.
Why are you walking towards...
Okay.
She's like, I don't want to be...
I don't want to live in Doki Lata anymore.
Wait.
Is that...
She's so...
She's like...
I don't want to come back.
I'm there.
I'm out of here.
I'm gonna live off the grid.
Valid.
Okay, I won't put you there, but you still have to live with
the rest of us.
You still have to be here.
Okay, wait.
Let me... I could tear for him, apparently.
Um...
Wait, how do I...
Oh, hey, she's not taking any chances.
All right, Dogenia put you somehow kudos to us, but also...
All right, sure, it won't be that as bad this time.
Oh, one of them died of old age?
How?
I...
What?
Oh, fuck it.
You just live there.
Fuck it.
We'll let her live there.
Well, the mage died?
Okay, how many?
Okay, I have...
Time for a field test.
I don't have mages left.
I think?
Okay.
I can sell from here.
Okay, I have one...
Okay.
I did lose a mage.
lose two mages.
Did I not?
No, I can... Yeah, because did I not have an upgrade that
said I can recruit multiple...
Let's grab this, too.
Oh, sure.
I can have, like, multiple mages.
But I have only one.
Yeah, but it says I maxed.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
I can only work two.
I didn't build two towers.
I don't even know if my mages are strong or anything.
You know what?
We'll build another mage tower.
And then...
Justin...
Oh!
A lone adventurer arrived in your town this morning.
Ragged and exhausted.
They explained that they are being hunted by a vicious pack
of manual wolves.
Okay, sure.
Hurtedly, the adventurer enters the town.
While they get cleaned up, a group of guards notice the pack
of wolves has begun to stalk your...
Oh, shit.
Okay, fuck.
Okay.
We're gonna put...
here just in case I swear to God the wolves show up here
okay we're gonna relocate you I actually don't trust you
anymore Doki I I do not for some reason I feel like maybe
you shouldn't be here anymore okay where can I relocate you
though okay maybe here maybe she'll be safe here the wolf
pack what do you mean the wolf me what do you mean
protecting.
We still need a name Quack.
He's so tiny that I can't click.
I can click.
He's so tiny.
Ow.
Quack, please.
Oh my god.
I can't click Quack.
I can't click on him.
No hitbox just like me.
Oh.
Oh, please.
Oh, okay.
He walked away.
He walked away, guys.
I was going to say this does not look too good.
I'm a little worried.
Can I not recruit another one?
How did you already died?
Why are you here?
Oh, my God.
No, do not...
we are we are we are make sure nobody does this one this one
people die people die there I can't believe he's dead again
I follow the shine of gold oh my god my mages are so
expensive but yet they're always the one that's dying oh hey
I got Wait, wait.
Building character.
Watch where you're stepping.
Well, hey there.
There he is.
There she is.
Um, this has been the smartest dokey.
Smart, smartest dokey.
She actually has chosen an area that isn't gonna kill her.
And that's wild.
She actually picked an air place.
She picked a place where she would.
die.
I'm so proud of her.
The smartest dokey out there.
What?
Who said that?
Yeah.
We should have, like, I really want to kill this one.
Wait, what?
I never clicked that.
Oh my god, no!
No!
Matthew!
I don't...
Okay.
Let's...
Let's get this out of here and can't hope and don't worry.
Third time's the charm.
Third time's the charm for Matthew.
Marthu will live Todd Kip
Uh Grab this Don't worry This is where things will go better
For us Okay We're in for the treasure Alright we'll grab
this We'll grab the healing guy I think the healing guy will
help us a lot.
Oh, okay.
At least Madden Heretic helped us out.
But it cost more, but it helps you.
Increases the target speed.
Let me rescue it.
Okay, we'll grab that.
And then we
also...
Oh, that's her!
You called the Heretic.
That's the Heretic!
It's killer!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Wait, how did she get crazy?
I'm looking at her.
Wait a minute.
Oh my
god, I fucked up.
Oh my god.
No, we killed her.
Stop fighting at these.
Oh no, this is so bad.
Oh, this is so bad.
bad oh my god please just try and kill at these oh this is
so bad oh oh
delicious oh my god what do we do oh they're killing
everybody they're killing everybody oh my god they're
killing oh my god
i don't know what to do i can't sweet i gotta kill her
michael oh my god she's killing all the dragon oh my god
excellent she's dead wait are they all dead
oh my
god they're all hiding in the market i'm sorry
Run, sir!
Chicken tenders!
No!
Chicken tenders, run!
Oh my gosh, she's still running out!
Someone kill her!
I'm broke!
Live by Yonder and die by Yonder.
I don't know what to do.
She's so strong.
How do you kill her?
She's killed.
Oh, my...
I think that town's gonna be okay.
I...
I think I don't
even know what happens they just they're evil I think I
think that town I think that town is gonna be okay why did
you just love her Toki you could have avoided this if you
just love her I
Maybe...
Guys, maybe...
As the first...
As the first character...
Might not have been the best idea.
Maybe...
Maybe we...
It might...
Maybe...
Maybe a Yonder is not the greatest idea for a love life.
Just maybe.
It's just just amazing
I don't I don't know For some reason I feel like maybe we
just can't fix it Am I crazy for thinking that?
Or is it me?
Maybe it was me guys Maybe I just didn't I should have loved
her more It was my fault you're so right guys It was my
fault I should have loved her more Oh I'm so stupid I should
have just loved her more.
It's never her fault.
You're so right, guys.
They can always be fixed.
I didn't...
It's never her fault.
True.
I was the problem.
Yeah, that sounds like quit or die.
Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is the day that I will live in infamy.
Remember the night of May 15th?
The night of...
Blood and screams.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, guys.
I'm going to call it here.
But again, huge shout out and thank you to Gold, Gold,
Adventure Gold for inviting me to be part of the game.
And give me my first professional voice acting gig.
My first voice acting job.
It's really cool.
The fact that, like, you always need it.
I'm an essential worker, too.
So your town always needs a dokey.
Thank you again, everybody.
I'm a caller here.
I might be playing Fortnite later today.
I won't be streaming it.
But as always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
Thank you guys all for the support, everyone.
Check out the game.
It's 40% off right now.
You can have your very own Doki on your very own farm.
Hey, guys.
Bye bye everybody, bye!